Гарними фотографіями можна заробити чимало грошей.
Зокрема, в Інстаграмі. На профілі привабливих інстаграмних "професіоналок"
підписані мільйони фоловерів. Як, приміром, Кайлі Дженнер зі США.
20-річна дівчина вже недалека до того, щоб стати доларовою мільярдеркою.
Чан Тавукчу працює модельним агентом.
Він підбирає моделей для будинків мод та глянцевих журналів.
Хто-хто, а він добре знає, в чому секрет ідеального фото для Інстаграма.
Кайлі, приміром, розтушувала свої брови за допомогою фотошопа,
а під очима зникли темні кола.
У переважній більшості випадків я однозначно можу розпізнати,
якщо обличчя "підправили". Звісно, вже є нереальні професіонали,
які настільки добре обробляють фото, що нема шансів розпізнати фейк.
Але переважно це видно.
Фейкова краса в його галузі - повсякдення.
На цій фотосесії в берлінській модельній агенції,
окрім фото, роблять також відео як доказ для клієнтів,
що краса справжня.
Єдине, що ми тут робимо, це дещо підправляємо фарби.
Приміром, якщо фото в занадто теплих кольорах,
тобто дещо зажовте, ми додаємо трохи холодних тонів, аби виглядало природніше.
Те, що клієнти далі роблять зі світлинами найманих моделей -
це вже справа клієнтів, а не Чана.
Фотошопи обличчя та тіла в цьому бізнесі - буденна справа.
За одне замовлення клієнти готові платити від тисячі до 20 тисяч євро.
Про те, наскільки добре нині розвинена техніка цифрової обробки
відео та фотографій, свідчить ось цей фейковий ролик
з екс-президентом Бараком Обамою, де той буцімто
нецензурно лається.
Це настільки професійно зроблено, що
навіть я не одразу зміг би розпізнати фейк.
Якщо б я раніше не знав, то подумав би: вау, це Обама таке каже?
Завдяки дедалі кращим комп'ютерним програмам
в майбутньому ще складніше буде виявляти маніпуляції
з фейковими відео та фото.
І це проблема не лише для модельного бізнесу,
але й у політиці для журналістів.